even with all our modern theories
the nature of gravity is still such a
mystery to us
what is it
where does it come from
unfortunately if you ask youtube these
questions
you're going to get some wrong answers
some very wrong answers
namely you're likely to come across an
explanation which purports that time
dilation is the cause of gravity
indeed almost as mysterious as the
origins of gravity
are the origins of this popular yet
confoundingly incorrect explanation
where did it come from
what does it mean exactly
and what can we learn about the actual
nature of gravity from it
this is dialect
with
the true cause of gravity
[Music]
understanding general relativity is no
easy feat
the central concept it relies upon
curvature
though mathematically well-defined
often eludes clear interpretation
indeed nowhere is this more apparent
than in a recent spate of youtube videos
all of which erroneously attempt to
attribute gravity and curvature to time
dilation
gravity does not warp the flow of time
it's the other way around the warping of
time causes gravity that's what i'm
going to show you right the type of time
dilation involved in that building
experiment is called gravitational time
dilation not because it comes from
gravity but because it causes gravity
on the surface these videos and their
explanations seem pretty cool and
convincing
each video starts out by noting that
the further out you are from a
gravitational mass
the faster clocks tick
this causes the clocks near the earth to
run slower than clocks far away
for example time passes more slowly the
closer you are to the earth when charted
out on a space-time diagram this leads
to a time gradient or temporal flow
about a gravitational mass
we have this sense of time flowing in a
gradient faster stream is distant from
the earth slower streams near it and
just like an object caught in a river
with an eddying current
any smaller mass near the central one
will be forced to rotate towards it
meaning rotated out of the time
direction and into the spatial direction
over time it points more and more toward
the earth parts of the object will want
to move through time at different rates
hence we have the appearance of a
gravitational attraction if you were
like us your first reaction upon hearing
this explanation was probably
whoa dude yeah whoa
that's freaking awesome
mind blowing
mass and energy cause time dilation
gradients
and time dilation gradients rotate the
paths of objects through space-time so
that they come together
that's gravity
it all seems to make so much sense
but then on further reflection
you might have started scratching your
head
wait
is the whole current gradient thing
supposed to imply that there's like an
inter-temporal force binding an object
to its future self
and which causes it to hold together
after being rotated by another sort of
strange temporally directed torque
like what
suddenly you're lost in a very murky
analogy
even matt from pbs space-time admitted
he was still a little confused by this
interpretation well speak for yourself
i'm still quite confused this raises
thorny questions well the reason for
your confusion is simple you're confused
because the explanation is wrong
one hundred percent
unequivocally completely wrong
it's astounding that not one of these
videos did their homework properly
because this entire interpretation
with its multitude of youtuber
proponents
and its millions of beguiled viewers
comes undone with just a few simple
considerations
now before we begin
we need to make some important
distinctions
there are three different phenomena
under consideration here
curvature
gravity
and gravitational attraction
[Music]
now in newtonian physics gravitational
attraction and gravity are one in the
same thing
masses are the source of a gravitational
force
gravity
which thereby causes gravitational
attraction
in general relativity however
gravitational attraction is only an
apparent phenomenon
it's fake
meanwhile gravity and curvature become
one and the same thing
where you have curvature you have
gravity
where you have no curvature you have no
gravity
and lastly where you have accelerating
frames of reference
you have apparent gravitational
attraction
so the first important takeaway here is
that this apparent gravitational
attraction is not gravity
that is it is not space-time curvature
now
half of these videos don't understand
whether they're trying to explain the
cause of apparent gravitational
attraction
or the cause of actual gravity
i.e space-time curvature
being separate phenomena
these two concepts actually require
separate explanations
and we'll get to that later
but at the moment this doesn't matter
because none of these videos succeed at
explaining either phenomenon
they're all wrong on all counts
to see why let us first consider a
uniform gravitational field
now the argument in all these videos
hinges on the fact that time dilation
gradients
that is clocks ticking at different
rates at different places
will cause different masses and objects
to come together
remember time passes at different rates
in different places
the heights of the clocks don't have to
be that different though
any difference will do
so imagine we attach two clocks to a
squirrel
one on his head and one on his feet
they should tick at different rates too
the squirrel's head moves faster through
time than his feet
this gradually turns his motion arrow
the squirrel falls to the ground simply
because time dilation exists
now
a uniform gravitational field has a time
dilation gradient
and certainly
at a place like near the surface of the
earth
where the gravitational field is
essentially uniform
objects seem to be drawn together
so
all good right
nope
why
because
the equivalence principle
the equivalence principle tells us that
a uniform gravitational field is
actually just an accelerating frame of
reference
imagine being on a rocket ship in outer
space
undergoing constant acceleration
according to your perspective there
arises a uniform gravitational field
filling all of space
causing clocks that are further and
further out from you
to tick faster and faster
now imagine coming to rest
suddenly all those clocks resume ticking
at the same rates
and the time dilation gradient abruptly
vanishes
if we accept the explanation purported
by these videos that time dilation
gradients are the cause of gravity this
would mean every time you accelerated
you would be inducing gravity
that is inducing space-time curvature
not only in your immediate vicinity but
across the entirety of the universe
curvature which would vanish as soon as
you stopped accelerating
this is patently absurd of course
space-time curvature is not an observer
dependent phenomenon
it is something that according to the
theory of general relativity
all observers will agree upon
no matter what their frame of reference
and a uniform gravitational field in
fact has zero curvature
because
there is no gravity there it's just an
accelerated frame of reference
alright let's return to the surface of
the earth
you're probably most accustomed to
experiencing gravity here in your
day-to-day life
it might shock you to learn then
that at the surface of the earth
there is no gravity
none whatsoever
the reason the apple falls to the earth
isn't due to the fact that clocks at the
top of the apple are
from the perspective of an individual on
the ground
ticking slightly faster than clocks at
the bottom of the apple
rather it's due to the fact that you the
observer
are accelerating upwards through space
at 9.8 meters per second squared
you and the ground beneath you
are literally rushing up to meet the
apple as well as towards anything else
that might happen to be
falling
at that moment
and that is the true cause of apparent
gravitational attraction
the fact that you're accelerating when
you believed yourself to be stationary
time dilation is a relative phenomenon
gravity as in real space-time curvature
gravity is not
the fact that clocks tick faster at
higher elevations is certainly true for
observers who are observing those clocks
while on the ground accelerating
however
if we transform into the inertial frame
of the free falling apple
the clocks at both its top and bottom
will be ticking at exactly the same rate
thus the fact that all these videos
attempt to assert that apparent
observer dependent time dilation
gradients
are responsible for real observer
independent gravity
is absurd and doesn't make any sense
but what makes even less sense is that
in promoting this idea
all these youtubers somehow managed to
completely forget the basic fundamentals
of general relativity
yet they're obviously not unintelligent
individuals so that leaves a whole new
mystery
where did this explanation come from
and why was it so convincing
the answer lies in a pretty simple fact
everyone who pushed for this explanation
mistook
a space-time diagram
for actual space time
to see what we mean let's turn to idea
lists video
despite being a smaller channel the
level of explanatory power and clarity
evident in idealist's video far exceeded
that of all the other channels
and we thank him for that because
without his video we wouldn't have been
able to get to the bottom of this
enthralling mystery
the white lines show that for an equal
amount of bottom floor hours higher up
clocks travel further in time an
intuitive way to estimate the geodesic
between two lines in this curved
spacetime is to start at a point on a
time grid line then use a circle to find
the shortest path to the next time grid
line let's think about an apple hanging
from a tree in this new context it will
follow its geodesic through space-time
its shortest path which just so happens
to coincide with the apple falling
towards the center of the earth in space
as you can see idealist notes that at
higher elevations where clocks tick
faster
the world line of an object on the
space-time diagram will be forced to
curve if that object wants to take the
shortest path between coordinate
grids but idealist's mistake here like
all the others
is that he interprets the space-time
diagram as being actual space-time
that is he thinks these objects are
actually curving through time and space
simply because they're curving on the
diagram
he conflates curved lines on a
space-time diagram with space-time
curvature
this is the sense in which space-time is
curved here
because the space time is curved
geodesics through it will also be curved
the space time is curved space time is
current
[Music]
now a space time diagram is a tool it is
not actual space-time
like taking the curved surface of the
earth and making a flat map of it
it is a representative depiction an aid
to assist in
understanding so if we want to know
where and how curvature appears
we need a mathematical test more precise
than simply pointing at curved lines on
a space-time diagram and going
space-time curvature
so here's what we'll do
let's note first
that mathematically speaking curvature
arises wherever geodesics on a surface
are either converging or diverging
consider two great circles on this
sphere for instance
note that
as we traverse them
the separation between these geodesics
either grows or shrinks
this indicates curvature
if the surface were flat the geodesics
would remain parallel and the separation
distance between them would never change
now let's return to the surface of the
earth
position a bunch of apples at different
elevations and release them
simultaneously with respect to the
accelerated observer on the ground
next construct a space-time diagram from
the perspective of this accelerated
observer
since the gravitational field that the
observer perceives here is uniform
all of the apples will fall at the same
rate
and their trajectories will form a
series of staggered parabolas
because the paths of all the apples were
inertial paths
we know that these parabolas are all
geodesics on the space-time manifold
now let's examine the separation between
these geodesics
notice something
despite all these paths curving the
separation between them never changes
this means there is no space-time
curvature here and thus
no gravity
now
if we zoomed further out
and dropped our apples from higher and
higher elevations
we would start to notice
that the separation between geodesic
world lines would begin to grow
this would indicate space-time curvature
this is where true gravity finally makes
its appearance
so when idealist and others thought they
were looking at space-time curvature
they were in fact looking at something
else
what exactly
well
let's trace this idea back to its
origins
you see pbs space-time acknowledges
borrowing this idea from the silence
asylum who probably borrowed it from
eugene kurtarianski
who probably got it from this dude
who in turn likely got it from this 2013
video
after that the trail goes cold but this
early video is enough to show us what's
really going on here
ready
watch
as you can see it's just a simple
coordinate transformation
specifically it's a coordinate
transformation mapping a parabola to a
straight line
and this curving on the diagram which
results from the rotation of the
coordinate system of the accelerated
observer
and not from the rotation of actual
world lines of objects through space or
time
everyone has confused for either actual
space-time curvature
or apparent gravitational attraction
so basically all of youtube got tricked
by a coordinate transformation
forgetting to remember that in
relativity
coordinates don't always mean what you
think they do
okay
now back to gravity
if all these videos are wrong
then what is the true cause of gravity
well that answer is the same one
einstein and essentially newton gave
mass and energy density
that's the only factor which determines
the amount of space-time curvature or
gravity in a given region
interestingly enough this means time
dilation has nothing to do with
curvature
in fact you can build a theory of curved
space time without time dilation
using only the classical concepts of
time and space from newtonian mechanics
it's called newton carton physics and
what it demonstrates is that general
relativity actually has a lot less to do
with relativity then its name might lead
you to believe
but that's a topic for another day
okay but the question that you've been
really asking yourself since this video
started is what causes two objects
seemingly at rest with respect to one
another to become drawn together
well to explain that you simply need to
invoke
gravity
the internal pressures within a mass and
apparent gravitational attraction
you see
no single mass is truly ever at rest
with respect to itself
this portion of the surface of a
spherical mass for instance
is accelerating out from the opposite
portion of that mass by a certain amount
while that opposite portion is also
accelerating away but in the opposite
direction
in fact every portion of a given mass is
accelerating away in a radially outwards
fashion from the rest of the mass
now such masses don't blow apart into a
hundred pieces
because real gravity space-time
curvature
steps in here to ensure the space-time
manifold is warped in just the right way
as to compensate for all that outward
acceleration and thus produce a stable
configuration
hence we have the appearance of a
universal attraction affecting all
bodies because every single mass in the
universe is literally accelerating
towards every other single mass
granted this is a very abbreviated
explanation
but it's a much closer step towards
understanding the truest cause of the
attraction between bodies
lastly we'll note that there is a way to
interpret an accelerating observer's
rotating planes of simultaneity as a
sort of one-dimensional temporal
curvature
however this curvature would not be
space-time curvature
rather it would be a coordinative
curvature which we could transform away
unlike real curvature
nor would it explain apparent
gravitational attraction since the
attraction between bodies in this case
is again obviously explained by the fact
that objects are just accelerating
towards one another
well this has been a lot so to conclude
for today
we will say that general relativity is
obviously confusing and we can forgive
these youtubers for getting it wrong
but the question remains will science
asylum pbs space-time or any of these
other big league bad boys acknowledge
their mistake and help to rectify the
misconceptions they've propagated unto
their millions of viewers
well we appeal to you our viewers
to take up this mantle and help spread
the word because frankly
we're exhausted after sorting through
this mess and we need a vacation
but don't worry
we'll be back
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
you